hello and welcome to clueless gamers the
first ever team multiplayer edition of
clueless gamer that's history kids today
we'll be playing one of the most
anticipated games of the year
halo 5 guardians for the Xbox one
today we're challenging three of the
stars of the HBO show Silicon Valley in
just a moment we'll join up no waiting
just a moment we'll join them on the
battlefield but first let's meet our
players
tu Coco Conan O'Brien Erin Laird Andy
Richter Team Silicon Valley Thomas
Middleditch TJ Miller Zach woods
I believe Team Coco is which color we
play red we are red and I am the team
captain for Team Coco by universal
decree Silicon Valley is going to be
blue your team captain Thomas right
there yes that's true yes he is the team
captain and one other thing
whichever team ends up losing their show
is cancelled it's a tie we don't exactly
we're all cancelling all right gentlemen
let the murder begin do we press the
start I just said let the murder begin
someone said which button do we put
battlefield fathom a Spartan research
base located deep below the waters of
the ocean planet Leah Gabriel five
minutes remain I don't know what's
happening
taking a walk through this underwater
engineering Junior solicit building of
them I don't see anybody I'm like my
father at night looking for friends the
middle Steve I hate it here your show
Cody the show I got my Etsy page
I spent personally most of the battle
alone shooting at the plate-glass trying
to let the shark monster in with you
guys in this next round just yell out
you who were over here just so I know
where the fight is god I'm still looking
for people
communities
you know
[Applause]
we are hopeful with this but also in a
way that's almost intriguing I did I was
killed several times yeah
raise your hand if you killed me so you
killed me
yeah yeah is there no sense of status
show business status I put on the year
twenty two years when you see me pass I
think of courtly bow and her wife mrs.
O'Brien
Conan we're three Hollywood Mavericks TJ
what's your motor stop around a how you
playing the game I killed you twice then
the first one was as sweet as the last
not a lot of remorse no I see no empathy
in your eyes and I'm a sociopath con I
took the test
have you killed Andy yet yeah kill that
a couple times one time I kill him he's
looking at his feet like you and the
problem is Andy went to this
subterranean world without his
medication I keep looking for the nurses
off what is your your plan here my plan
mostly just to take a little me time and
and to find a quiet corner in which to
be reflective okay because there's a lot
of violence happening but who's who's
remembering it gentlemen we are now
moving to a different world we will now
be on top of a skyscraper and I'd like
to see how these Silicon Valley guys end
a little altitude
the towering skyscrapers and Noctis the
capital city of amnesia hey Conan you
just flip the script but you still gotta
read the words let's do this I'm not
sure I even understood what he said turn
the tables but your feet are still going
to be under it oh my god
[Applause]
okay let's do one where we don't kill
each other
we just walk up to each other and talk
yeah let's do it
sorry Thomas hi Miami I'm good how are
you behind good oh yeah you're a nice
man oh hi I spin around a little bit
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh PJ this is why were starving
[Applause]
all I care about is that I took a life
I'm gonna call my mom
gentlemen would you be willing to play
one final game winner take all yeah you
are into that okay one of the
proposition Thomas I have $500 in cash
here I will give it to you with you will
replace Andy on our team 500 clams
Andy just stay where you are and you
don't let anyone touch it yes I did no
that was okay Annie it's really fun to
fail on two different teams I'm just
killing everybody
[Applause]
Thomas sold-out dominance we weren't you
out of the house by five well let's be
chillingly honest we were soundly beaten
by Silicon Valley gentlemen you played
as a team but I think you all deserve
trophies so oh yeah here we go
there's only two well you won't play
pretty much equally well mine has Papa
Oh
pretty much speed really well there was
some disparity in your skill set you
better believe it
okay we're not free straining so that
was a wasted effort and I'm still
talking nope it's not gonna freeze right
we're not gonna jump if you like and
nope didn't because I control the show
well there you go
the game is halo 5 guardians guardians
and it comes out October 27th October
27th all right you guys had the thrill
of beating us and you one massive
trophies but there are one small
consolation is that it's my studio I
control the jump and freeze and man
we're gonna have one great summer
[Music]
[Applause]
as well as a Laval takes at team coca
calm slash blue is Gamera we'll take a
break we'll come back